welcome to this video playing MH 1919
aged to 1982 probably let's see what's
happening here another NIMS oh and I can
report that I'm on a great winning
streak in case you don't believe me that
I actually am on the streak here it is
11 out of 11 and they're all on the
channel I only didn't upload a draw that
I played against a friend of mine the
other stuff is all on the channel so 11
out of 11 so let's see maybe I can
continue the streak for the end of the
year - to get to 2500 again would be
funny okay this guy here has allowed me
to play a 4 and this is something that
white should really do okay hmm yeah
this is of course reminding me a lot of
Sahaba a lot of the same issue Airy
Asian that I have played so often pretty
nice one where a three wasn't possible
it wasn't necessary and I'm also
threatening a 45 now I run directly
oh he's knowing that I can also play if
I go Bishop d3 se5 maybe come on let's
push this
Queeny force is another move with the
tempo and Bishop III and switching over
to the Kings side of course my structure
is terrible with those pawns but what
can you do
Nagi for losses to to Queenie for so 97
is pretty much the only move okay an
interesting moment now if I go Queenie
for yeah yes the place is 6 really he
has to I think there is no way to trap
my queen sometimes there's a wait Bishop
d7 takes 95 uh uh embarrassing he could
have played no I can take the Roku ha ok
this session already takes a while and
sometimes it it you really feel it when
you don't talk this kind of nonsense
thinking about miracle defences a
prominent okay so f5 here or g6 um my
idea with this h7 made is pretty obvious
if he goes g6 he's threatening night c5
so I have to BM have to be alert there
that I don't um don't allow that easily
g6 maybe Bishop e3 simply to to take
this not losing time ok went f5 that was
the principled alternative if I take it
I mean think about it man and I think I
should take so now I only have Queenie -
basically I have to keep the the bishop
protected and yeah my hope is that the
weaknesses on e5 and e6 will be good for
me yeah this is actually a move that I
like I was thinking about it just trying
to catch my queen in the middle but I
have to take it I think especially I
cannot come I cannot allow we should
reform the problem is that I have this
move I asked our Bishop chief for
interesting
now okay yes Bishop g4 that's that's
nice but I can play Queen c2 and castle
next no alternative Bishop f4 was just I
don't know this is looking wrong we
should keep this ship f4 I need to
support the knight reliably that was a
good move e5 it just activates black if
he just sits still this will be really
terrible and yeah this is this is just
not clear at all okay let's get this
King out of the middle he will get the
pawn back but what I will have is an
excellent pair of bishops Bishop f4 and
there's also still this pressure against
h7 which will be very relevant I think
oh that's not good I believe he has to
misplace their this is a misplaced rope
here this should move rook to you one I
guess I don't know maybe he can't play
that but it looks it looks weird it
seems even better than t1
yeah I think I have to regroup him still
Roop do you wanna maybe it was better I
don't know difficult this is a difficult
position it looks it looks good for
white to be perfectly honest but it it's
not easy to play the one Bishop deform
okay I cannot working over shifty for
immediately which is maybe the best way
to do it threatening just Bishop takes
f6 harming a spawn structure and yeah
that that's good
also it's still somewhat mysterious what
the look is doing one in five or in
general on the fifth rank supporting
this bishop
look H who I go to g5 was my idea that
should be quite good
also intending sacrifices then like rook
f6 rook a to cringey v Bishop d6 rook
takes f6 for example should be really
dangerous
I wonder if I should go see five for
Bishop c4 trick maybe not totally
convincing okay
still I have to play and it is the most
active move that I see so I'm going for
it he takes root Bishop c4 check King h8
and then what oh it's not doing that I
thought this was almost almost forced
hmm I still attacking this but no no my
queen really gets activated him can
check now here for pawn time marking up
for me I probably should do that there's
also there's also Bishop g4 coming Queen
d2 I have the Czechia and Bishop g4 is a
huge threat black for effects on time I
keep forgetting to check the clock yeah
I was I saw that I have a little bit up
on the open time but not that I'm not
that far ahead
yeah that was tricky if I've was a
really good defense so this this this at
least it was very very tricky right here
there are the compass
okay now it changes his mind
you should f4 and long castling yeah
this was interesting certainly but it
looked very shaky to not have f4 as a
really reliable protection of this piece
what this is it's using White's big lead
in development so there is a real logic
to it yeah but as so couldn't I couldn't
bring myself to do it you know this is
super tricky the comp is just a 0.8 0.9
so we're not like is simply we know
anything but here he definitely is
somewhat in the game I still thought you
should just go back a rupee six or
something
this looks looks kind of weird but maybe
it's not that bad back here trying to go
to d4 which I know did I didn't really
see that move coming until an
interesting line if he takes I thought
this should be good
and it wins okay I had the right hunch
there something like this is it's very
strong made and also this stuff okay so
he went here and c5 is the strongest
move good yeah good it is the strongest
move according to the comp it frees
everything up but I thought he would
take I didn't think about this one Queen
g5 here this is actually completely
winning I like +8 okay there's also an
additional problem if he does something
like that I'm picking up this rook which
I didn't see at all until you
overstepped the time right yeah where
there's no movie this is the main thing
Bishop to e6 and and it's it's over this
rook is like totally offside okay well
thanks for watching